-The last time you were here
was the day after the election.
-When you didn't
want to talk politics.
You only wanted the funny.
-I did.
You were the perfect tonic.
-Yep.
-So it's so nice
to have you back.
But I want to ask,
before we get started,
on Halloween, you had a scary
moment during your show.
-Oh, gosh.
-You fainted.
-Have you ever fainted?
-I have never fainted.
And it happened during the show.
It was on camera.
Did you know what was happening?
I, having never fainted,
I don't know what's going on?
-Yeah, there was a tune-up,
where I felt it.
You know, I felt something
was about to happen.
And I fell gracefully,
'cause I was
the Statue of Liberty.
But my -- my --
-Right, it was Halloween.
-My headpiece
stayed on and everything.
--Wow!
Yeah, I fell on my tailbone
and rolled onto my back
ever so gently,
and not one black-and-blue mark,
not one bit of pain
in the morning.
-Oh, that's amazing.
-However...
And, also, I was also only out
for three minutes --
or, three seconds,
so I was able to come back
and finish the show.
-That's amazi--
-Yeah.
-The incredible thing
about that,
that you finished the show
after fainting,
you have done --
you just passed
the 1,500-show milestone.
-Yes.
-Incredible.
You're in your ninth season.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes.
-And 1,500 --
you have never missed a show.
-I've never missed a show.
I mean,
I've done the show with a cold,
which, I know, don't judge.
[ Laughter ]
I won't be doing that any more.
But I've done it with a cold,
you know, fainting
and then getting back up
and powering through.
Everybody was worried about me.
They wanted me to take off
the rest of the week.
But you know what?
I found out I'm low on sodium.
So I'm the one
who's shaking like crazy now.
-Oh, good.
-Drinking a lot of electrolytes.
-That's exciting to find out
you're low on something
delicious like sodium.
-Like sodium.
[ Laughter ]
And as a result, dehydrated.
-Yeah.
Oh, right, of course.
When you went into this,
did you think you were
the kind of person
that could do 1,500 straight?
Have you been healthy
your whole life?
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
-I mean, not healthy,
but who's gonna pay my bills?
-There you go.
-You know what I mean?
-So, more driven than healthy.
-Yes, yes, yes.
-You have been rewarded
for your drive.
This is very cool.
You come from Asbury Park, yes?
-Yes, I grew up --
Well, I was born in Asbury
and raised in Ocean township.
-And you got a street sign.
You got Wendy Williams Way
right there.
And you go back and visit it?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I do, I do.
That street, it used
to be called Central Avenue,
and now it's called
Wendy Williams Way,
and my home is on the street,
which I love that.
Thank you, Asbury Park.
I go back and visit
to clean up to be sure --
Okay, nobody's littering.
-Oh, wow.
-Nobody's doing anything crazy.
-You take it very seriously,
having your own street.
-Oh, yes, I do.
And I bring a stepladder,
because a lot of times
people leave, like,
notes in ziplock bags
so they don't get wet.
-And they leave it on the top?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And so what do they say?
-"How you doin'?"
or "I love you,"
or, you know, "Call me,"
or, you know,
something like that.
-Wow! It's so great,
in the age of social media,
that people
are still doing signs.
[ Laughter ]
Like, you have
a Twitter account, right?
-Um...
-All right.
[ Laughter ]
That's very --
That's really cool.
-No, we do,
but it's for the show.
-So I want to ask about
"Ask Wendy."
This is something
you do on your show.
Been doing it a long time.
-Yes.
-And people have been getting
more comfortable over the years.
What was the difference
from what people would ask Wendy
in the beginning versus what
people would ask Wendy now?
-Well, in the beginning,
it would be something like,
"Do you think that these frames
are good for my face?"
You know, a woman wearing
glasses or something like that.
-Uh-huh.
-Or, you know,
"I was thinking of dying
my hair, you know, brown,
and what do you think?"
you know?
"Oh, well, you don't
look nice as a blonde."
And now, honey...
[ Laughter ]
I get asked about threesomes.
-Oh, wow.
-Oh, yes.
I get asked
about affairs with bosses.
-Really?
-There was a woman who was --
who was a Dean at Harvard
who was on today,
and so she says to me,
she says, "You know, Wendy,
there's this woman
in our social circle,
and she kisses my husband.
She takes his face
and kisses him on the lips
ever so gently,
and she does it all of the time.
And I notice she doesn't do that
to any other of the other men
in our social circle."
-So what did you tell her to do?
-Tell her, "Milly,
you know that thing that you do
when you touch my husband's face
and kiss him on the lips?
Don't do it."
[ Laughter ]
"Would you like
some more beans?"
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah!
-Is it key, then, to make sure
you have beans before you do it?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]